[Music]
all right let's go out to Columbus Ohio
and talk to Amanda what's up
Amanda hey John what up uh not much so
I've got a uh pretty big question here I
am okay go for it worried I am worried
that um our 5-year-old may be
traumatized after accidentally
witnessing my husband and having
sex I'm worried that there may be some
negative down stream effects or I'm just
hoping I'm
overreacting okay I gotta paint me the
whole picture here pain tell me the
story okay so my husband and I are super
careful about making sure that our door
is closed and locked but apparently her
ninja skills she snuck into our bedroom
and hid in our closet it wasn't until I
went to the closet to get dressed and
flipped the light on
that I see her there with her face
buried in her knees so naturally I go oh
my God jump out of the doorway throw on
a Rob and asked her what are you doing
in here she apparently had had a
nightmare and had snuck in there before
you got the door closed oh she had a
nightmare all right yeah she had two
nightmares concurrent we call it wow
yeah okay um how how comfortable are you
with me asking like real questions here
go for it okay um and this isn't me
being
um uh like just trying to be like I
don't know over the top this is me like
asking like for real questions okay
absolutely
um was it boring under the covers
married sex or were youall getting after
it I wish it was the boring under the
[Laughter]
covers okay fantastic even better even
even better um where she was sitting
technically she could have seen
basically
everything lights on or
off uh there was TV light so it was
illuminated yeah she said she didn't see
anything well of course of course well I
mean 1,000% and let's be like what she
hear
right I'm sorry what did she hear
there would have been some sounds yeah
yeah we're expecting our fourth so I
mean I don't even know what that has to
do with this but that's fantastic oh man
so again I'm not trying to be gratuitous
um I'm trying to paint get a picture of
what this 5-year-old experienced right
what she saw what she heard um all right
so like yelling or anything like that
but I mean it wasn't silent
okay um do y'all I mean was was there
did she hear things that would have
scared her that's the question yall talk
dirty to each other was their role
playing or was
there you see what I'm saying yeah it I
I don't think there would have been
anything like that okay that was just
baby one and two not three and
four all right so um she leaves you open
the door un like um fully unclothed and
there's your child how old is she five
five um clearly in a like terrified
position right and you jump back grab a
rope then what happens tell me tell me
how you walked through with her what
happened next so I brought her over to
me and picked her up and just very
calmly I was very careful about like my
body language and tone asked her why
what she was doing in the bedroom and
that's when she said she had had a
nightmare and then I asked her did you
did you see anything she's like no and
then I um proceeded to say well if you
did I'm I'm really sorry if you did that
wasn't meant for your eyes that's
something that's for adult husbands and
wives perfect she hasn't said anything
about it it's been a week but you know
I'm worried yeah so okay you handled
that about as perfectly as you could
handle
that okay um I'd be willing to bet
99.999% chance she did see some or all
of of
everything um and again there is a
difference between we're under the
covers and explaining that like she's
seeing like what looks like under the
covers wrestling if you will and in
those kind of situations often what
scares a kid is she sees a different
face on Mom or she sees a different face
on dad that she's never seen before she
doesn't have a she doesn't have a
psycholog she has angry she has joyful
she is frustrated she doesn't have
ecstasy she doesn't have um that it's
just a different face right and so that
often doesn't compute with a kid and it
can scare
them then there's explaining oral sex
and then there's explaining oh no
I I like it when fill in the blank right
that's a totally different conversation
and so I think you did the exact right
thing number one kids are going to
absorb your body language
and so if you're not freaking
out oh my God but it's like no no no we
were totally partying and we're married
it's what we supposed to do a it's
awesome B and C you weren't supposed to
see that because that's for adults
that's
grown-ups and so you handled that
perfectly kudos to you high five all
right so um did you ever walk in on your
parents not that I remember
no no my my my mind blocked it out all
of it all of it all of it um okay so
what makes you think this is a you've
ruined your child or you're G to scar
your
kid I don't know I feel like I worked so
hard to try and like put up safeguards
like with using the internet and all
that stuff just to make sure that they
don't accidentally see like
inappropriate or pornographic images and
I feel like I've failed her in that
because she witnessed that okay I think
what the question you're asking is so
important and so I'm really grateful
like and so I'm laughing cuz I have a
seven-year-old and a
13-year-old and to my
knowledge they haven't I'm I'm just
laughing because God Almighty like the
this can happen to all of us right um
but the question you're asking is really
really an important one okay so number
one you and your
husband rocking on till the break of
dawn in your bedroom in your home is not
por
pornography MH and I think we have a
habit of dumping all sex into something
illicit is it too is is a 5-year-old too
young to see what she saw absolutely no
question about it but there is a
difference between her mom and dad and
pornography okay and so a you didn't
ruin your
kid your kid's gonna have some stories
to tell make no mistake about that um
for sure like 100% but you didn't ruin
anybody okay okay
um paint me a picture of the
conversation you have had with with her
and your other kids about sex before or
is this this the first time uh no so we
were trying to make it like a not
necessarily common conversation but one
that's not so awkward okay um like they
know correct anatomical terms that those
areas of their body are not bad areas of
their body it's just they're for them
and not for other people
okay um that people shouldn't see it
people shouldn't touch it um that sort
of thing okay um so you have done a
great job of what I'd call priming the
conversation I also think that this is
the awkward part where parents wait for
the kid to say something I've heard
parents tell their kids um if you ever
have any questions just come ask me
which is you might as well tell your kid
never ever talk to me about this ever as
long as you live right because no kids's
gonna ask their parents after getting
caught with like looking at pornography
on the computer or getting caught like
hooking up with their boyfriend or
girlfriend or nope K parent no kid is
gonna be like all right Dad I'll come
ask and actually no kid's gonna do that
and so I think this is where you have to
head directly into the
awkward and um I I like these along
gender roles right now um I think it
can
um it doesn't have to be but I I I I
think that's a safer way to do it right
now given your home context but I would
take your daughter out and make it
something like kind of a special take
take her out and say all right we have
to talk about the other
night and say I'm not mad in any way
you're you need to not sneak into mom
and dad's room and you know that but I'm
not mad at you at all but it is
important for me to know what you
saw and if she says nothing I promise I
promise um say it's
I would I would push a little bit and
see and if she doesn't want to see I
think then if you haven't explained
here's how sex actually
works and
um like Daddy's part goes inside mommy's
part this is how this works um then I
would have take that time to have that
conversation there so you're going to
start to give her language that she may
not have yet or she may have it but not
know if it's okay to say it out loud and
also here's the big thing you're going
to talk about sex and how it works and
how great it is and the importance of
what context it's good and what context
it's not good and more important than
the actual words you're saying is she's
going to totally absorb your body energy
and if you are awkward and freaked out
and scared to death and oh my gosh I'm
terrified to even be having this
conversation she will put a GPS pin in
sex is not okay to talk with mom about
all right I don't want that exactly
right and also you probably don't want
to you don't want to explain uh oral sex
to your 5-year-old either right you
don't you don't do that either so none
of this is is like awesome or ideal but
this is our role as parents right
absolutely but the calmer you are the
more you smile the more you laugh the
more you what did you say have you that
kind of thing and then being real clear
about here's the context that's I
think's important for us one last thing
I would add oh so let me stop you there
so tell me is that ringing true does
that feel right um are there oh yeah I
can totally do that that's not going to
be a problem okay
um do you believe her that she didn't
see anything or do you think she
did I think that she saw something and
maybe got scared and HIIT her face okay
all right one question that kids often
feel internally when they catch their
parents having sex is it appears to them
that somebody's getting hurt MH and so I
think it's important to say mommy was
not getting hurt at all in fact mommy is
really enjoying herself in a private
adult
thing and often that's the fear is
somebody's getting hurt or I don't
understand what's happening here if she
saw more then she saw more and y'all can
kind of dig into that a little bit um
and I wouldn't press it but what I would
do is maybe put a pen in it and circle
back to it in a couple of weeks and then
Circle back to it in a couple of weeks
and um the safer she feels to have a
conversation about it then it will
hopefully it will it'll eventually
emerge there you may also want to give
her just a small bottle of bleach so she
can rinse out her
eyeballs I know I feel so
bad oh my gosh hey here's the last thing
here's the last thing um I would it
so I'm about to talk about Santa Claus
and so if you have kids listening to the
show you might want to Shield their eyes
I mean their ears from what I'm about to
say three two one all right so I
recently had a conversation with my
daughter about um I need to have a
grown-up conversation with you and it
has to be a private conversation that
I'm having with you and we explained to
her for several reasons that Santa Claus
is not real and walked her through it
and I every step along the way I told
her we're having a grown-up conversation
and this is not for you to share with
your
friends and I told her about a time when
I was a kid and I blew it I told a bunch
of my friends that Santa wasn't real and
I actually hurt people and I didn't mean
to I was just trying to be the
know-it-all idiot kid and so I told her
that she can really hurt people and ruin
some of the magic if she tells her
friends so this is just private between
us and she really took that to
heart and so I would reiterate with your
daughter that this is private things
this is not to be shared with her
friends at
school okay and remind her she's only
allowed to have secrets with you with
Dad or with the doctor that's it that's
the only people she can have secrets
with and but this one is going to be a
private thing between you and Dad and um
her okay is that fair yeah that sounds
super straightforward I can do that and
I don't mean this in a in a erotic way
way so I wouldn't say like I I would
like
to I would love for you to call back and
walk me through how you and your husband
the next time y'all are about to hook up
that you start in one corner of your of
your bedroom suite and just go every
square inch I can't can't I'm scanning
the whole house
now I can only only imagine that's how
that's playing out that will never
happen again if I have anything to do
with it it 100% will hey what about your
husband what did he have to say about
it oh he was slightly mortified but he
figured he's like oh she'll be fine
yeah on behalf of mental health
practitioners around the country we
thank you for your future business
Amanda um both of you you may want to
make a small account just on the side
just a high yield savings account you
can put a little money in because she's
going to need to go to counseling and
talk about this but um not really I I
don't think you you you've done such a
great job job
norming talking about body parts norming
what's okay and what's not okay
particularly
norming
grown-ups in a married loving
relationship can do this right and it's
okay A and you weren't supposed to see
this um this wasn't for kids to see so
um you did great hey if you are watching
this um or listening and you haven't had
the body part conversation there's a
great book by Julie federo it's called
some parts are not for sharing some
parts are not for sharing by Julie
federo um it's a tiny tiny little book
but it is a fabulous book to walk
through um really really excellent
excellent book
um best of luck to you Amanda and
everybody check your
rooms and on behalf of your kids lock
the door
he